eric delannoy je vous présente
économistes et alors vous êtes lié avec
masque c'est parfait président du
cabinet tenzing conseil jean sébastien
ferjou bienvenue directeur d'atlantico
merci à tous les deux donc c'était le
psychodrame autour de l air voilà notre
premier sujet hubert falco qui claque la
porte du parti l air il se dit qu renaud
muselier ferait de même dans les heures
qui viennent peut être même dans les
minutes qui viennent
jean sébastien ferjou c'est une réplique
du séisme muselier ce qui se passe là
c'est en train de ces cette droite qui
est en train de se déchirer alors qu'on
pensait hier soir que finalement tout
allait bien façon ces termes accord de
dupes la droite a beaucoup perdu dans
cette affaire là d'autant qu'elle voyait
venir la faire de longs instants jacob
était parfaitement au courant des
intentions de monsieur mme joly est
simplement jean castex et a pris au
piège en annonçant dans le plan national
finalement cet accord là plutôt que ce
soit fait juste et la méthode qui les a
pris de court beaucoup plus finalement
que le fond de la faire ce qui est
inquiétant c'est qu'il n'est pas juge
venir le coup c'est ça le sujet mais il
ya beaucoup d'hypocrisie en feignant de
le découvrir vous de l'avoir découvert
dimanche mais ne pas l'avoir anticipée
est un vrai sujet après moi je trouve
que monsieur falco pour le coup et
cohérent il ya rien d' indignes a
négocié avec la république en marge soit
s'allier avec la république en marche
encore faut-il le faire justement de
manière claire et pas dans cette espèce
d'entre deux cas pratiques et monsieur
muselier que je trouve
choquant enfin je connais christian
estrosi qui pourrait démissionner dans
les minutes qui viennent et les heures
qui viennent c'est pas du tout renommée
je me suis trompé mais oui parce que ça
sera en plus étonnant geôliers qu'après
cet accord était déjà un accord de dupes
parce que quand il dit oui madame fusent
elle devra démissionner du gouvernement
si elle veut si elles souhaitent être
sur la liste suffit-il de quitter le
gouvernement pour changer d'identité
politique parce que moi j'ai envie de
retourner la question à ce compte là est
ce que monsieur muselier en remerciement
de ses bons et loyaux services changera
d'identité politique le jour où ils
rentreraient éventuellement dans un
gouvernement de monsieur macro enfin on
voit bien que tout ça est quand même
assez consternant d'autant que pendant
ce temps là rien n'est dit sur le fond
de la campagne sûr que monsieur zier il
dit pas nous avons des convergences sur
le taux d'ailleurs de compétences qui
sont celles des régions donc et au delà
de serment jeudi pour les républicains
si certains parmi eux avait encore
l'espoir de faire une primaire tout
espoir est définitivement envolé parce
que là qui pourrait douter que ça se
termine autrement que celle du ps en
2016 et hier on en est convaincu pour
vous c'est à dire que vous voyez bien
que la d'avec le genre d'accords de dieu
auquel nous avons assisté hier qui
pourrait croire que l'engagement de
soutenir le vainqueur qui est a priori
le fondement d'une primaire ça se
finirait comme pour le ps avec un manuel
valls qui avait claqué la porte et
plusieurs candidats qui avaient claqué
la porte du moment où c'était benoît
hamon qui avait gagné
donc je pense que les républicains ont
beaucoup beaucoup perdu à cette affaire
en essayant de ménager la chèvre et le
chou en général quand on ne choisit pas
c'est le pire danger aux cadences exposé
qu on dit du côté de la droite eric
delannoy c'est que en gros la république
en marche c'est aimer annuel macro le
premier a fait un bon coup quoi un bon
coup politique
avec quels risques quand même un bon
coup politique oui en même temps il n'en
restera finalement peut-être que des
miettes
enfin qui va quand même arrangé la
république en marche parce qu'il faut
pas oublier que la problématique de la
république en marche celle entre à
l'ancrage territorial l'ancrage
territorial c'est la première élection
régionale faut pas l'oublier
c'était la première action municipale
faut pas l'oublier et donc il est
difficile de raisonner
avec des appareils classiques qui a faim
dans une logique d'appareil classique
quand on sait que ce mouvement-là ce
parti-là n'a pas du tout d'historique
donc quand on parle d'échec faut
relativiser et du coup le la stratégie
du coucou qu'avait évoqué un politologue
c'est connu est une stratégie qui peut
permettre d'accélérer l'ancrage
territorial
plutôt que d'afficher des victoires
potentiellement irréaliste
aujourd'hui on n'a jamais vu un parti au
pouvoir avec l'usure du pouvoir gagner
facilement des élections locales ce qui
permet de gagner élections que le
loquace et les ancrages historique qui
créent des inerties j'ai des bastions
socialistes et si julien pouvoir
socialiste qui se passe mal je réussi
néanmoins à limiter les dégâts parce que
je veux je parie sur une passionnée le
thé local la république en marche ne
peut pas jouer sur ce sur ce schéma là
donc il est très difficile pour elle de
pouvoir s'ancrer sur des listes propres
donc ça c'est quand même un point qui
est très important à noter d'où le fait
de tenter des coups
d'où le fait de tenter des coupes comme
ça à un accord qualifié ce qui est
n'importe quel prix mais moi je parle
pas de la république en marche vous
parle de la démocratie non mais la
démocratie de toute façon je vais vous
dire moi ce qui est en train de se
passer là à titre personnel qui qui
regardent la politique d'un peu loin
quand même
c'est quand même ce qui nourrit la
défiance des français visée du politique
c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois qu'on met
l'appareil devant l'intérêt des des
électeurs on nourrit la défiance du
politique je veux dire on se sent bien
que derrière cette histoire là certes il
ya à fronton qui consiste à lutter
contre le front national leur assemblée
nationale contre les extrémismes on peut
espérer que le fond du sujet il est là
en tout cas pour renaud muselier à titre
personnel je pense que c'est une il ya
une sincérité lié à son histoire
1 mais mais mais globalement la réaction
des appareils de droite où la tentation
de nationaliser ce débat-là par la
république en marche c'est une logique
d'appareil qui est assez consternant
entre 200 et
quelque chose peut-être oui certainement
on il ya quelque chose à mon sens plus
inquiétant encore si relire les
républicains sont incapables de se
montrer à la hauteur de ce qu'est leur
rôle le premier parti d'opposition du
pays parce que si on regarde en nombre
d'élus quand vous cumulez les mairies
des collectivités territoriales le
parlement les républicains sont le
premier parti d'opposition de ce pays
dont ils sont incapables de se montrer à
la hauteur de ce rôle presque
institutionnelle en quelque sorte et
deuxième point parce que je trouve très
inquiétant de la part d' emmanuel macron
c'est ce jeu dangereux avec la
démocratie parce que vouloir incarner
comme ça toute la politique l'érable en
bourgogne on aurait pu alors ça a fait
capoter l'opération
mais on aurait pu s'allier avec
finalement la présidente sortante
socialiste mais en paca on va s'allier
avec renault mais jonnier s'allie avec
renaud muselier s'est aussi eric ciotti
yankee et dans les alpes-maritimes
donc j'aimerais qu'on m'explique quand
même la cohérence qui existe entre la
candidate socialiste en bourgogne et
eric ciotti je ne la vois pas et donc
cette espèce de prétention à vouloir
incarner le champ politique entier de la
gauche à la droite et finalement ne
laissant sur les marges que des gens qui
m a même macron désigne comme étant hors
du pacte républicain la france insoumise
où le rassemblement national je trouve
ça grave parce que quand vous créez un
système où l'alternance n'est pas
possible ou alors elle ne paraît
possible que justement en piétinant un
certain nombre de valeurs républicaines
vous créer une situation où la seule
issue est la violence et ce jeu très
dangereux parce que qu'est manama
concernant la poursuite qu'ils soient
habile vis-à-vis des républicains qui
voient les fractures et la droite
personne ne va lui reprocher de
poursuivre son intérêt électoral mais
pas à n'importe quel prix et
certainement pas au prix la démocratie
parce qu'il s'est quand même fait élire
en prétendant être le meilleur rempart
contre la démocratie n'est content pour
la devant la démocratie je ne peux pas
souscrire à cette analyse parce que
je pense que manu mais maintenant on n'a
pas tous les pouvoirs là dedans il peut
jouer des coûts effectivement mais il
n'a pas tous les pouvoirs n'oublions pas
qu'en castex et sûrement saisi de ce
dossier là l'opération du saint-esprit
on a connu un jean castex attend les
verts implicitement laissé ma
m'expliquer quand je dis qu'il n'a pas
la possibilité d'avoir tous les pouvoirs
là la vraie raison et ceux qui jouent
avec la démocratie sont ceux qui ne
parviennent pas à créer une colonne
vertébrale d'opposition mais public à la
surface
emmanuel macron il n'y peut rien si la
silla doha fi de la situation trip to be
profite d'une situation mais en quoi il
ya un risque pour la démocratie je veux
dire les hauts risques pour la
démocratie car n'est la totalité car il
occupe un espace là où les autres sont
incapables de l'occuper non n'oublions
pas que la république on marche s'est
créé sur la volonté de résoudre les
problèmes des français en sortant des
appareils malheureusement il ya une
ambiguïté très forte c'est qu'en sortant
d âpres ailleurs on recrée un appareil
la république en marche qui a du mal à
d'ailleurs également trouvé sa colonne
vertébrale parce que justement elle joue
très large en jouant non pas sur les
appareils mais en jouant sur les
convictions que on peut mettre en place
une alternative à des partis politiques
qui ne faisait plus rien le problème
c'est que ces partis politiques se sont
ôtés d'être évident au sol ces indices
coureur seul
sinon c'est cher mais c'est pas du tout
un discours hors sol il ya eu des
réalisations qui ont été faites des
réformes qui ont été faites bien plus
que certains camps quinquennat donc
c'est pas hors sol ce qui est hors seul
c'est le simple fait que les oppositions
se sont auto détruite en 2017 et
qu'elles ne parviennent pas à se
reconstruire
macron n'y peut rien acer est ce point à
16 à ce sujet là améliorée plus qu'elle
n'empire
il aurait pu construire un parti parce
que mais c'est assez compliqué n'ont
jamais rien investi de manière générale
il a toujours méprisé si ce n'est
piétiner les corps intermédiaires que ce
soit justement les syndicats que ce soit
le parlement que ce soit les partis et
il n'a rien investi dans la république
en main aucun effort dans la république
en mars donc je suis d'accord avec vous
les autres positions une responsabilité
accablante et je vous le disais sont en
deçà de ce qui devrait être leur rôle et
leur attitude de ces derniers jours a
été consternants pour autant la
prétention de monsieur macron incarner
la totalité de la rhk politique en tout
cas de là les autres lancements il ne
prend pas les pattes mais c'est ce que
c'est une escroquerie intellectuelle
monsieur que de nous essayer nous conte
que le clivage entre nationalistes
contre je sais pas quoi pendant le
clivage il ya bien des manières
différentes d'envisager l'europe parce
qu'en tant je suis pro européen
peut-être géré de manière différente
d'envisager l'avenir des clivages la
meilleure qui va sortir grâce le front
national parlement national s'affaisser
à faire aussi mais oui les médias les
mac rien télé mais pas du sénat le
démocrate de monsieur draghi n'est pas
la même que la vision de l'europe d'un
du gouvernement espagnol je vous assure
c'est pas c'est pas le sujet mais
pourtant il serait le sujet j'ai essayé
on a parlé back gauche droite
probablement qu'il est un peu suranné et
devrait laisser la place à quelque chose
d'autre qui demande à s'exprimer mais
qui n'est plus aujourd'hui le clivage
qui permet d'exprimer la politique
française c'est ce qui nous on va
continuer de parler de cette campagne
des régionales et départementales qui a
une autre info aux supputations du jour
qui nous vient d'rtl et politico eric
dupond-moretti serait en discussion pour
être tes de nice la république en marche
à la place de laurent petit rashevski
dans les hauts de france selon france
inter le ministre devrait effectivement
joue un rôle actif
cela pourrait être d'ailleurs
officialisé dans les heures qui viennent
ce midi gabriela talent n'a pas confirmé
écoutez je m'exprime assez peu voire pas
du tout sur les questions de politique
électorale ou partisane dans ce cadre là
je le fais régulièrement sur vos
plateaux ou en répondant à vos
interviews ce qui m'arrive assez
régulièrement c'est encore le cas hier
soir dimanche dernier ce sera encore le
cas en fin de semaine notamment sur
france 3 ce dimanche mais donc vous
comprendrez que je ne vais pas ici
parler de ces échéances je crois pas que
ce soit le lieu et le moment puisque je
suis là dans mon rôle institutionnel de
porte-parole du gouvernement
eric delannoy dans le cas des hôtes
france là aussi la république en marche
cherche à faire battre xavier bertrand
c'est ce qu'on comprend s'ils veulent
maître eric dupond moretti une figure
plus connus peut-être plus populaire est
encore que je ne sais pas dans le nord
pour faire battre examine bien sûr mais
on cherche un bon la république en
marche cherche à s'imposer
c'est compliqué de s'imposer dans un
système politique dans lequel vous
n'avez pas d'histoire et sur lequel en
plus la défiance par politique
s'installe donc forcément on est en
train de se dire
une fois une figure qui est connue
puisque le pouvoir ne permet pas d'avoir
légitimité pour pouvoir s'y mettre donc
c'est aussi la même raison pour laquelle
darmanin se présentent au mieux au
départ pour avoir une légitimité
supplémentaire une figure qui puisse
permettre de dire voilà on va incarner
quelque chose donc ça me parait ça ne
leur est pas illogique mais ça arrive
mais quoi les idées des manuels macro et
l'ancrage territorial d'un parti qui se
construit les favelas moi je me régalais
la logique de considérer que monsieur
ciotti est un allié en paca et que
monsieur père monsieur singh et tout un
tas lui même et monsieur sua s'alliant
avec monsieur johnny vous voyez bien que
c'est ce qui se passe bien sûr mais non
il peut crétine mais ya pas dix pour
regarder ça m'amuse de ce qu'est la
droite mais passe et à la difficulté
analyse et ça ça me ça me rappelle la
campagne de 2010 est je me régale encore
de tous ces analystes politiques qui ont
connu la politique française qui sont
capables de sortir des chiffres surtout
les comportements politiques de la
gauche de la droite et chivu s'est
expliqué pendant des mois et des mois
pourquoi emmanuel macron ne pourrait pas
gagner
après vous expliquer pendant des mois et
des mois pour me emmanuel lès mâcon et
pourraient ne pas avoir des majorités
mais représentait une autre question
c'est en mai sa plus basse et que les
jantes avec le logiciel d'analysé droite
parce qu'il ait pas de gauche il y aura
de droit comme monsieur castanet
lihrmann quelque chose on peut dire
comme surtout après le quinquennat
abscons et plus en 2010 est un mythe en
2017 et monsieur macron admettons a vu
une semi cohérence dans ses propos
mêlant design cohérence dans sa folle
idylle a dit pas seulement ont scellé
n'importe quoi il est allé sur tous les
territoires
quand monsieur castaner dit comme il l'a
dit cette semaine que finalement on est
dans le dépassement politique peu
importe qu'on soit de gauche ou droite
souvenons nous au passage d'ailleurs
qu'il avait fallu à l'époque que manuel
valls quasiment le menace pour qu'il
accepte de retirer sa liste afin que
monsieur estrosi puisse être élu mon
bref entre temps il a vu la lumière
mais quelle est la logique sur quels
critères quand monsieur castaner nous
dit nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est une
bonne idée casque une bonne idée qu'est
ce qu'une bonne idée monsieur parce que
moi après avoir vu emmanuel macron avant
le coc vie pendant le coc vide ou avant
les gilet jaune pendant le lise
je ne sais pas si sciatique sébastien
c'est un prennent de l'eau c'est
effectivement peut-être un peu cela il
sera à metz que ces termes on encore du
sens être de droite être de luca scassa
du champ là la preuve bien sûr que ça
dure non mais la porte le nom s'est
classé glané deux choses mais non je ne
sais pas parce que vous avez des mauvais
médecin en l'occurrence des mauvais
parti qu'il faut renoncer aux principes
de la médecine la droite en général à
une sensibilité qui fait que entre la
liberté et l'égalité elle préfère la
liberté la gauche préfère l'égalité
après vous pouvez décliner sur des tas
de choses et je vous assure que dès que
vous parler d'immigration
dés que vous parlez de questions
éthiques sur des tapis il ya des sujets
parti qui savent je suis consterné de
voir intéressant de répondre à des
propos terminée oui mais il faut laisser
génial ça mais bon moi ce qui me
consterne c'est de dire mâcon est un
caméléon mais mais mais d'abord vous
qu'on s'adapte à des à des séismes comme
le co vide ça me paraît un peu logique
mettre en place un programme
présidentiel
quand il arrive une crise sanitaire ça
n'a juste aucun sens donc on peut pas
parler de caméléon on peut juste se dire
qu'il ya un président qui se préoccupent
de la santé des français bon ça c'est un
premier élément
deuxième élément la stratégie des
manuellement france a été une stratégie
qui a été très clair depuis le début des
voiliers des possibles par l'opposition
qui était de libérer et protéger la
logique la vision de d'emmanuel macron
de la société française s'est libérée
pour faire la création de richesse est
protégée pour faire en sorte que tout le
monde en profite et les lois qui ont été
votées lassus sont sur cet axe là que
vous vouliez ou non il ya des bilans qui
sont là on peut parler loi par l'oie moi
je le connais un peu pas dire il faut
plus du tout parler de droite ou gauche
moi je pense que le clivage gauche
droite et est inscrit en histoire aux
flèches d'analyser correctement les
situations et qui faussent l'intégralité
des analyses et qui fait qu'on est
capable de dire n'importe quoi c'est
emmanuel macron est un caméléon mais non
enfin je veux dire aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron a fait la cré a géré la crise
sanitaire comme il pensait la gérer
il ay l'un pas renoncer à son programme
économique est un programme
d'émancipation des freins économiques de
la france
il ya des lois qui sont passés là dessus
il ya d'ailleurs des succès qui ont été
qui ont été vus là le la gestion du coc
vide a montré son efficacité que ce soit
sur le plan économique
où que ce soit pour le sur le plan
social et pardon pour le terme
efficacité parce qu'avec le nombre de
morts client peut pas vraiment parler
d'efficacité mais en tout cas on a
limité les dégâts de manière extrêmement
forte et ce qui se passe aujourd'hui les
cohérences qu'il ya notamment par
rapport à un adn de la république en
marche c'est au moins ne jamais se
composait avec les extrêmes faillir
quand vous avez le programme de 10
municipal l'acce c'était ne pas composer
avec les extrêmes sur les régionales ça
sera pareil donc avec renaud muselier
avec trône au lycée dont monsieur
partiellement ou plus à ce que madame le
pen en lui expliquant mais monsieur le
terrain mais darmanin n'est pas du tout
à droite monsieur vous fait des
généralités qui malheureusement sont
sans parler de gel sur cire j'écoute ce
que disent les membres du gouvernement
spa et jeunes gens lancent leur
d'acronis n'est pas une vision politique
c'est un saint simonisme c'est à dire
cette prétention que l' expertise en
quelque sorte les expertises dépolitiser
tombé du ciel par des gens plus
intelligents que tous les autres et on a
bien vu comment monsieur macro plus
d'une région très haut débit
centralisant totalement la décision et
en étant incapable d'ailleurs de
s'appuyer sur la société civile parce
que en matière de libérer protéger je
peux vous dire que la crise du coville
ça aurait été une excellente deux
occasions de le démontrer il n'ya
soit-il direction il n'y a pas eu une
relation d énergie 13 à andrezé les
entreprises quand elles ont essayé à
blizzard exemple demandé dès mai vous
pouvez regarder
nombre de morts par million d'habitants
vous verrez la 24e la france au 24 mai
look et combien 24e malades et les pays
du nord qui ont des conditions
spécifiques c'est vrai mais 24 ans que
chez moi on peut comparer par rapport à
la belgique on peut par rapport par
rapport au royaume uni par rapport aux
états unis la france et 24e donc sam
dans un score non mais non je sorte que
temps suffisamment long du monsieur
trump avait ravagé les etats-unis
comptent des proches et des courbes à
fin juin nous aurons le même rendement
dans les cheveux potentiellement ils
auraient agi mais sont anciennes
sociétés en meilleure santé globalement
parce que vous aurez des revenus des
sociétés monsieur calade l'oscd soyez
pas aveugles quand vous avez 49% des
français mais vous risquez sont en
faveur d'un recours à l'armée mais même
sans sollicitation du gouvernement
c'était en bonne position d'acs
intelligente belle bien sûr vous amène
au troisième chapitre la présidentielle
effectivement elle est encore loin
d'être écrite vraiment un candidat hors
système pourrait-il émerger et renverser
la table en 2022 ce n'est pas moi qui
pose la question c'est la question que
pose laetitia cru pas qui a patiemment
attendu derrière son écran bienvenue
donc voulu lier votre avis la tentation
du clown merci d'être avec nous dans ce
match votre livre sans le 6 juin
si je ne me trompe pas il sort demain
abba voyez je me suis complètement
trompé un candidat hors système va
bouleverser l'élection présidentielle en
2022 c'est ce que vous pensez après
cette enquête après ces témoignages que
vous avez recueillis oui c'est
l'intuition que j'avais au départ il ya
un peu plus de deux ans qui a été
finalement vérifier puisque je suis
parti à la dent l'enquète de et pour
répondre à cette question et j'ai été
voir 50 personnalités 50 experts j'ai
mené 50 entretiens chez sur le terrain
aussi dans les coulisses du pouvoir pour
comprendre s'il y avait un espace un
espace pour un candidat un candidat
qu'on dit hors système alors je
l'appelle clown parce que généralement
ça fait partie du job politico
médiatique
vous le savez vous savez très bien
rebecca
on maudit clown pour celui qui va sortir
du chapeau finalement celui que
n'entendez pas le candidat surprise la
outsiders et il me semble que tout où
tous les experts que je suis allé voir
tous les experts ont cette même
intuition et me démontrer point par
point qu'un espace existe sûrement au
premier tour pour un ou plusieurs clown
parce qu'ils sont peut-être plusieurs
sur la ligne de départ qui pourrait être
quelles pourraient être ces clowns je
vois que vous évoquez les noms de didier
raoul qu'eric zemmour jean marie bigard
cyril hanouna c'est ça oui alors il y en
a certains qui ont déjà été candidat
vous le savez jean marie bigard a fait
acte de candidature avant finalement de
se rétracter donc ce n'est pas une
nouveauté mais cyril hanouna c'est une
petite musique qu'on entend depuis un
petit moment et je montre dans le livre
vous le verrez comment le pouvoir
finalement instrumentalise cette
candidature pour en tirer profit vous
verrez comment emmanuel macron tire un
peu les ficelles donc oui il ya beaucoup
de monde beaucoup de pistes finalement
que j'évoque beaucoup de personnalité
que je teste dans ce livre et vous
verrez que honnêtement ils sont quand
même plusieurs à avoir toutes les
chances de leur côté
il ya des phrases qui ont un peu filtré
de votre livre qui croît le plus et qui
croient le moins dans ce que vous avez
interviewé je pense notamment à gaspard
grande soeur qui lui semble y croire
vraiment oui gaspard deux heures me dis
qu effectivement ce n'est pas le seul
arrêt des cars et me dit que il voit
dans la dernière ligne droite
un candidat surgir un candidat qu'on
n'attendait pas alors le seul atout
qu'il pourrait avoir et qui est
fondamental pour cette quête élyséenne
c'est d'avoir déjà une popularité un
socle de popularité parce que sinon
quand on arrive comme ça à la fin vous
le savez d'une campagne c'est difficile
de remporter la mise mais c'est
complètement possible aussi qu'il crée
sa si vous voulez sa notoriété sa
popularité en dehors des radars
traditionnels c'est une des
caractéristiques du cloud c'est une des
caractéristiques que j'évoque et que je
creuse
en ce livre grâce à encore une fois
l'apport de sociologues de chercheurs
politiques qui kroes la question encore
aujourd'hui c'est une question qui
vraiment est au coeur est au coeur de
toutes les études sociologiques
politiques et au coeur du pouvoir
également voulu et je oui et non on
regarde ça de près et effectivement même
au plus haut niveau de l'état gabriella
talent oui il gabriela talent alors lui
apparemment il n'y croit pas il dit que
la crise sanitaire a changé la donne et
que ça ne pourra pas arriver
vous savez à rebecca gabriel attal me
répond donc il répond à une journaliste
indépendante qui fait une enquête
donc il dit bien ce qu'il veut dire moi
je peux vous dire pour avoir quand même
fréquenté un ses coulisses du pouvoir
dans cette enquête qu'il y a des doutes
en tout cas qu'ils savent tous qu'il y à
cet espace qui existe et que même le
pouvoir pourrait avoir tendance à encore
une fois surfer sur cette vague puisque
le pouvoir et j'explique encore dans l'
enquête lance lui-même les ballons
d'essai il est resté avec nos laetitia
cru pas on va continuer d'en discuter en
plateau et n'hésitez pas à intervenir si
vous le souhaitez c'est une hypothèse
qui vous semblent crédibles jean
sébastien ferjou qui est un espace pour
le premier tour oui je lirai avec
attention le lit de laëtitia krupa c'est
toujours intéressant les échanges qu'on
peut avoir avec elle après en tant que
potentiel politique réelle non je n'y
crois pas une seconde
parce que nous sommes un pays riche
alors c'est dur à entendre pour un pays
qui est en crise pour un pays où il ya
beaucoup de chômeurs mais malgré tout
nous sommes un pays riche terre coeur un
clown littéralement le clown l'humoriste
en ukraine qu il a été élu et il faut
pas confondre en fait des gens qui sont
des populismes et qui vient du coeur de
leur parti comme boris johnson ou donald
trump avec des candidats totalement hors
système parce que dans il ya une logique
institutionnelle c'est à dire que
emmanuel macron ce deal a fait campagne
en six mois non mêmes macron il commence
et il avait commencé à constituer ses
réseaux depuis la commission attali
cantalès au financement d'une campagne
parce que tout le monde semble oublier
ça mais le financement d'une quand il
faut beaucoup d'argent faire une
campagne même emmanuel macron quand il a
commencé à aller voir les banques a eu
de la peine à les convaincre allez vous
à l'époque où il paraissait loin d'être
une évidence dans les sondages c'est
encore un filtre est à dire qu'ils y
aillent
il ya à la fois il ya l'aspect
médiatique des choses et on peut
imaginer effectivement un candidat en
souvient de coluche en 1980 dans un
autre registre qui commence à prendre la
lumière à prendre le vent qui après il
ya la réalité et je crois que les pays
qui sont prêts à l' aventure politique
sont les pays qui n'ont plus rien à
perdre et nous sommes un pays qui a
encore beaucoup de choses parce que il
ya des retraites ceux qui ceux qui
votent ce sont des retraités ils ne
veulent pas perdre leur retraite
il ya des gens qui ont de l'epargne on
en a encore plus depuis la cri du coq
vide il ya des gens qui ont des trains
afin qu'ils bénéficient transferts
sociaux
c'est un peu la même chose qui pèsent le
même plafond de verre indépendamment de
toute considération idéologique qui
pèsent sur marine le pen dans l'it quoi
dire que la question de la compétence et
les majeures c'est pas parce que les
gens ont des envies effectivement de
peuvent être séduits par des
personnalités comme eric zemmour cyril
hanouna et d'autre et s'assure un
premier tour je suis d'accord que l'ex
passe existent pour que ces candidats là
peut-être puisse faire du bruit dans le
cadre d'une campagne présidentielle que
à l'arrivée ça stration ça se traduise
par un score un minimum conséquences
pour toutes les raisons que j'ai
évoquées j'y crois maintenant pas tout
de suite ou non jamais non on ne dit pas
non jamais je ne dis pas non mais encore
une fois je ne dis pas que ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il puisse pas y en avoir un
et prennent la lumière et qui à un
moment donné gonfle mais qui à mon sens
unis par dégonfler parce que justement
les gens ne veulent pas prendre de
risque on a encore trop de choses à
perdre alors les dix siècles pas
m'engager et je vous donne la parole
vous promets rick moi je vous donne
rendez vous jean sébastien dans un an et
et nous verrons parce que tout ce que je
sais c'est que je ne sais pas après ces
deux ans dans quelle je peux vous
assurer que tous les spécialistes
vraiment sont convaincus et ont fini par
me convaincre un vous le verrez dans
libre point par point
nous listons tous les signaux verts qui
s'allument un par un en france pour
qu'un clou il puisse exister dans cette
course élyséenne
et vous avez raison jean sébastien s'il
fait par exemple entre 10 et 15 % non
non on ne sait pas du tout ce que va
donner
l'abstention si les abstentionnistes
décide d'aller voter parce que
finalement ils sont convaincus par ce
que une personnalité réussi à les
fédérer et ça c'est une piste un combo
donne aussi dans l'anc est que beaucoup
de sondeurs aussi ont testé et bien
écoutez on n'a aucune idée du résultat
et si il fait entre 10 15
jean pour semble le cloud peut être
chaud heures de roi donc rendez-vous
dans un an jean sébastien on en
rediscute l'idée de ce livre
jusqu'à ma parole de deux secondes
c'était justement de lancer cette
discussion pour qu'on puisse avoir un
état de lieux avant le premier tour et
que ce ne soit pas le lendemain qu'on se
dise mais que s'est il passé
refaisons le film je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous l'été ça c'est une
très bonne question et non mais moi non
plus je crois pas enfin je pense qu'on
se fait peur avec ce type de pronostics
maintenant faut pas le négliger
néanmoins bon allez enfin les arguments
que j'ai envie de retenir à part ceux
qui viennent d'être exposé sur lequel je
suis assez d'accord c'est un je pense
que les figures dont on parle fonds sont
finalement des figures médiatiques molle
enfin je veux dire quand on parle de
zemmour zemmour il fait un super score
sur ces news mais ces news ces huit cent
mille personnes qui regardent tous les
jours et avec un public très fidéliser
qui représenterait même pas 1% des
électeurs donc je pense pas que dans la
population globale
une france global ces gens là est un
quelconque impact qu'ils allaient qu'ils
aillent être des titis enfin viennent
titiller les candidats en place et les
scellés les candidats système pour leur
faire dire pour venir un peu perturber
le jeu électoral c'est probablement pas
impossible ça c'est première réunion il
ya un argument qu'on n'aime pas voir en
france parce qu'on adore le pessimisme
et on adore les scénarii catastrophes
dans ce pays mais il faut bien voir
qu'en début de l'année prochaine on va
avoir une super bonne nouvelle c'est que
normalement sauf si un 40e variant qui
arrive normalement on devrait quand même
revivre à peu près normalement
et ça je pense que peu de personnes
imaginent l'impact psychologique positif
positif que ça devrait avoir sur la
population française quoi qu'on en dise
quelles que soient les conséquences
qu'ils aient eu sur cette crise du coc
vide mais déjà tout le monde se réjouit
de pouvoir les en terrasse le 19
mais quand vous allez pouvoir enlever le
masque vivre normalement depuis vous
posez la question du confinement mais ça
devrait avoir je l'espère en tout cas
titre personnel un impact positif et
d'ailleurs emmanuel n'a plus de quoi se
payer et bien sûr mais alors là encore
la fin les études de l' ocde montre que
les revenu en france ont été les
mieux préservées de tous les pays mais
je parlais de s'arrêteront ils y ont
défailli et c'est pour ça qu'il ya un
travail sur le fait que les aides ne
s'arrête pas aussi brutalement que ça
bref il ya tout un travail pour faire en
sorte que ce qui est là d'une arrivée en
talisman de la campagne met donc donc du
coup mécaniquement ça va à mon avis
donné beaucoup moins d'audience à ces
faiseurs de haine ou saas et cloud
effectivement j'aime bien les
inondations en profite ce le moment
justement en fait le moment est mal
choisi je pense que c'est le retour de
la crise de coliques qui va rendre ces
gens là - et inaudible que ce que kim
peu le reste que dans le cadre d'une
dune comme gage d'une dune du vin d'une
crise comme locaux vides et dernier
point c'est que il ya deux clowns qui
existent déjà quand même enfin
seba jean luc mélenchon aujourd'hui tel
qu'il est tel qu'il est tel qu'il
fonctionne et marine le pen par rapport
à ses propos je veux dire ne laisseront
jamais émerger des gens comme ça ils
essaieront de les récupérer donc d'une
manière ou d'une autre et enfin le
dernier argument c'est que il ne suffit
pas c'est quand je parlais ce soir là
prétendent mais il ne suspend la nôtre
il ne suffit pas par ailleurs et enfin
il ne suffit pas par ailleurs de pouvoir
prétendre qu'on va être un candidat
antisystème
il faudrait déjà défini ce que c'est
qu'un candidat antisystème il faut aussi
proposer une offre politique la raison
pour laquelle le sait le legi les jeunes
n'ont pas réussi à à perdurer c'est que
l'offre politique est très compliquée à
mettre en place quand on est un clown et
sans offre politique on ne va pas au
bout d'un d'un jeu électoral il ne reste
qu'un second envie de répondre je pense
pas confiseurs que jean luc mélenchon
marine le pen soit déçoit des clowns on
peut être parfaitement en désaccord avec
leur proposition je ne pense pas qu'on
puisse dire qu'ils soient des clowns
mais maintenant dernier argument c'est
que finalement les français ont élu
emmanuel macron qui sur le papier était
brillant il était le coeur même du
système
et pourtant il s'est largement planté en
tout cas dans la perception qu'en ont
les gens et vous verrez que même après
le toujours c'est laisser gère la
meilleure que ne peut arriver je les
méprise mais l'insécurité
non mais ce que jugent loisirs peut-être
que l'année prochaine qu'il ne sera plus
là et encore me préparant pas le
déconfinement donc on s'expose au risque
un nouveau variant mais l'insécurité
elle elle sera trouvée merci merci
beaucoup les thyssenkrupp page rappelle
le titre de ce livre mercy corps donc
demain et pas du tout le si georges il
dit n'importe quoi c'est la tentation du
ce clown merci en tout cas merci à tous
les deux d'avoir participé à ce match
des idées on se retrouve demain 18h
22h30 vous connaissez le rendez-vous
maintenant demain bonjour chez vous dès
7h30 oriane mancini recevra notamment
philippe juvin chef des urgences à
l'hôpital européen georges-pompidou mère
l air de la garenne colombes et lui-même
tête de liste dans les hauts-de-seine je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée sur
public sénat